nous sommes devant la scène de la royale
factory à versailles en compagnie de
marie leur boucher bonjour bonjour vous
êtes la directrice du café-théâtre lever
de rideau vendredi 21 mai après
quasiment un an de fermeture alors
comment vous organisez cette réouverture
tout d'abord on est très contents de
réouvrir le théâtre on a dû aménager les
horaires à cause du couvre feu donc 19
heures les représentations lieu de 20h30
ça fait un petit peu tôt j'espère que
les gens pourront s'organiser pour venir
nous nous retrouver on a réduit notre
jauge donc on peut accueillir 60
personnes au lieu de 180 donc il y aura
de la place il y aurait des espaces et
l'avantagent qu'on a c'est qu'on a un
centre de traitement d'air donc en fait
l'air est renouvelé on continue donc
c'est pas tous les théâtres qui avance à
nous on a la chance de l'avoir donc vous
pouvez venir en toute tranquillité il
était assisté le spectacle est alors que
justement quelle est la programmation à
venir
alors donc on va démarrer le 21 donc à
19 heures avec karine dubernet donc
c'est un one woman show donc c'est une
artiste qui raconte sa vie en fait
donc elle va présenter toute une galerie
de personnages donc c'est très drôle
c'est très frais c'est très dynamique
qui m'entoure je vous invite à venir
découvrir ce spectacle là encore des
places disponibles il y a de la place
donc vous pouvez acheter vos places sur
le site du théâtre
ensuite on va enchaîner le week end
après avec une humoriste qui s'appelle à
maya qui est un humoriste originaire des
yvelines et qui parle de la normalité
donc comment être soi-même dont dans ce
monde
dans le monde actuel vous êtes un des
rares théâtre privé dans les yvelines
beaucoup ont été subventionnés justement
cette année vous en tant que théâtre
privé comment ça s'est passé
alors donc l'état a aussi mis en place
des aides pour les théâtres privés donc
la royale factory tient debout on sera
toujours là
donc elle nous a vraiment on a vraiment
bien été aidé donc on a pu payer nos
charges
évidemment on n'a pas gagné d'argent
cette année mais le théâtre sera
toujours là pour la rentrée vous avez eu
des échos des aides de l'état
tout à fait elle ne fonctionne la
solidarité le chômage partiel donc ce
qui nous a permis de maintenir le
théâtre à flot marie-laure boucher
d'avoir été notre envie de rien versé